♪♪
Foreman:
Keep moving!
Get that rock outta there!
♪♪
What you see on camera, it's a
hard thing to explain, but it
set me into a mindset of the
seriousness of the material.
Will Smith:
It's like these environments are
talking to me.
♪♪
This movie looks completely
different than any other film
about this subject matter.
Antoine Fuqua:
Aesthetically and also the
journey that Peter went on.
The idea is that in every frame
it’s evocative and informative.
Trying to capture the beautiful
and the brutal in the landscapes
of Louisiana.
It really is an energy.
You can really feel it.
♪♪
Naomi has done a brilliant job
of recreating the reality of
that time.
Todd Black:
From building the
horse-and-buggy carts,
Todd Black:
recreating slave shacks,
to building the railroad site,
Todd Black:
to building the battlefield. On
and on and on...
I love Naomi, she’s so
passionate.
Antoine Fuqua:
You give Naomi direction,
she’ll build you the world.
The windmills pump water,
which then goes into the
cistern,
which then feeds the, um, steam
cars when they come through.
Naomi Shohan:
I build in shots, lighting when
it’s interior.
I build in a lot of stuff
Naomi Shohan:
that a cinematographer can then
discover.
He is my strength,
and my defense.
Overseer:
That still ain't fast enough!
He has become
my Salvation.
Naomi Shohan:
I am completely motivated by the
way
that the story is going to be
received by the world,
Naomi Shohan:
but I measure my own success on
whether it shoots well.
(Grunts)
(Chains clanging)
♪♪
For me as a cinematographer,
Robert Richardson:
I search for something
extraordinarily real.
Robert Richardson:
Antoine and I felt that what had
been accomplished in the
Robert Richardson:
past with color is something we
didn’t want to repeat.
Robert Richardson:
So we looked for a palette that
was black and white,
Robert Richardson:
yet allowed certain colors to
come out of it.
Robert Richardson:
So it’s not a completely black
and white,
but it’s a heavily desaturated
feel, a grittier feel.
Will Smith:
The desaturation of the film and
the look,
that was really critical for
capturing the brutality.
Robert Richard:
Peter’s constantly on the run,
so his camera is virtually
always the same:
Robert Richardson:
always in motion.
♪♪
Dodienne:
(French Creole)
♪♪
The scenes in which we’re
shooting Dodienne,
Robert Richardson:
we slowed it down, and were more
stable,
Robert Richardson:
so that you have the fixture and
a more
Robert Richardson:
structured background for her
in combination with the race
that’s taking place between Peter,
Robert Richardson:
trying to avoid Fassel and his
men, who are hunting him down.
Runner.
(Bell rings)
Runner!
Little girl:
(Bell rings)
Runner! Runner!
Little girl:
♪♪
Well I’ve always been a history
buff.
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
I’ve always been interested in
the origin of things,
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
why things are the way they are.
Francine kept it honest as far
as the
Antoine Fuqua:
wardrobe and the look.
♪♪
There were fabrics back then,
they were called “Negro cloth,”
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
now called "Osnaburg," and it is
a rough grain, very scratchy.
So I like the fabric, but let’s
get something that is a bit more
comfortable.
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
And that’s where I really wanted
to go with cotton and linen blend.
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
Peter was running from these
vicious
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
people who are trying to
capture him.
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
To go on that journey with him,
we actually had seventy shirts,
seventy trousers—all of these
things had to have a multiple of
seventy with his first outfit.
(Dog barks)
The first time those iron
collars got put onto my neck,
Will Smith:
it was like comprehension
slightly beyond your rational mind,
Will Smith:
where things come through
that you haven’t thought about.
Will Smith:
It was like stuck on my neck for
probably fifteen minutes.
People were running around
looking for a key to get it off
of my neck,
but Peter was being beaten while
he had it on his neck.
♪♪
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
To see my journey through this
industry
Francine Jamison-Tanchuck:
as a Black woman, and a Black
American woman,
I think my ancestors would be
very proud.
Antoine Fuqua:
Obviously we still deal with
things today,
but I think part of healing is
trying to find some truth in it.
Antoine Fuqua:
And so that’s my journey.
That’s the journey that all my
crew came to join.
Antoine Fuqua:
So hopefully that’s what we did.
♪♪